One of the problems in health care
is that we have broken cultures
in health care.
And that senior doctors
or especially hospital administrators
don't know what their job is.
When you ask them,
"What's your priority?"
They say "patients."
No, it's not.
It's to take care of the people
who work in the hospital.
You take care of the people
who take care of the people.
That's what you do.
Every administrator and every senior doctor
and senior nurse
should be preoccupied with one thing
and one thing only:
are my doctors OK, are my nurses OK,
is my staff OK?
And if you get that right
they will devote all of their time and energy
to taking care of each other and the patients.
The problem is we have cultures
in which they think money is more important
or patients are more important
or anything else other than the doctors,
the nurses and the staff.
And so the doctors, the nurses and staff
are forced every day
to spend time and energy to protect themselves
from their own leaders
and take energy away
from doing the right thing for the patients.